bullet cat podcast
we got the homie in here man slim faux
honey welcome sir listen bro you got
your new albums officially out bombed in
yeah talk about
first of all i feel like this album
because i i went through the whole joint
last night
yeah and i feel like you might have had
a chip on your shoulder recording this
[ __ ]
oh yeah man um i'm about to bro like
[ __ ] it's hectic now i just feel like
you know i feel like
this album to me for you is like
a statement yeah yeah
was it that yeah bro i feel like man you
gotta make your point yes i'm saying you
know
a [ __ ] real bomb the native you just
i'm saying i already
do this [ __ ] from my city you so i'm
saying in my culture so
i have to just let people know man like
like a [ __ ] really come from spruce
street you say i'm saying the block
i'm saying along with a couple other
people you feel me but it's different
from me because i already was running my
[ __ ] running around doing
some [ __ ] unnecessary things right right
so
um i just have to just tell my story of
um what i was doing and
me going through the shootings and all
type of different [ __ ]
i do feel like one thing i've always
appreciated about you slim
is wherever i be i see you i might be in
san diego or f6
djing some hood ass [ __ ] and you'll be
there we're probably 405 [ __ ]
right in and out like you you're [ __ ]
out outside bro like
you know what i'm saying like that'd be
the thing not to catch you why but
people be like man like where he be
where he be man y'all don't be nowhere
because
i'll run cause you'll be everywhere that
part man so
you feel me people want to talk man say
that [ __ ] about [ __ ] man but
after i got even after i got shot you
feel me i was about 15 what
15 days i think i got shot i'm back
outside about two years ago
a year and a half yeah and a half now
yeah it was a while it was about a year
and a half yeah
straight to the studio can't walk proper
but i'm outside you feel me
it's crazy because um when you go
through a situation like what you went
through
it has to kind of put things in
perspective
does it kind of give you like a
does it check you to kind of re re-check
what your priorities are in life
yeah man how are you living i used to be
living reckless you feel me just
straight up i'm gonna keep it 100. but
now
it's like a have a certain couple of
people with me
then my extra eyes we in and out you
feel me ain't no lollygagging
as far as drinking liquor drinking
around my homies not being belligerent
in public because
well people you don't know yeah that's
when you get caught slipping
tighten up a lot of things bro yeah i
feel like um
when you got shot i was like [ __ ] i feel
like i just saw you in san diego
like not too far before i was like damn
i hope the homie pulls through
you getting shot i feel did you
did you um cause when something like
that happens to you in life
you're going to get a lot of people
hitting you up who might not have been
talking to you prior
did you notice some
some some some fake energy [ __ ] coming
around like during that time
because whenever some [ __ ] like that
happens i feel like
everybody's gonna come out the woodworks
make sure they check in
but it's like where were you at like a
month ago type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
i feel like um you know that come with
this rap [ __ ] you for me
that's a rap game half of the [ __ ] fake
but for the most part you feel me my
real ones that i already had songs with
or
really no personal without even having
songs they
texted me you said i'm saying my phone
is off at that moment but when i got
back home
i turned it on this [ __ ] steady ringing
it's like all right i like that from the
people that i really mess with
thoroughly
but um you know all the the rap [ __ ] now
you feel me
i pulled through and pulled through i
won't ah highlight your bloody
that's the fake [ __ ] so it's 50 50 man
and
i try to weed it off you know what i
mean by this being respectful but
knowing that they gonna [ __ ] with me
like that or like
you weren't even caring about my
situation or even what i was doing prior
to this you feel me so
i taking around with it man yeah man i
feel like the rap game is so finicky man
it's a lot of associates but not a lot
of friends you know what i'm saying
like in this game bro not like that but
you don't got no friends in this game
you already know what it is you see you
might see someone at the club be like yo
let's do something
you never hear from him [ __ ] until you
run into him again until you run into
him again to the same [ __ ]
yeah let's say you know what it is that
part that should happen a lot
that [ __ ] man look i don't do that [ __ ]
that's why that's what's the difference
between me and other people was like
i hold it down and make it make my word
of like what i'm gonna say i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do it you feel me like
like a lot of people just you know they
just talk a good one
so get take me back to the moment you
got shot man because i feel like that's
gotta be a pivotal moment in anyone's
life when someone tries to take your
life and you survive
how did like you know what do you
recollect from that day
like that moment that all the crazy [ __ ]
i was doing like i said
loaded riding around the city just
for nothing you feel me i was just
coming from my folks house but
i could have left i got on the freeway
and got to go got the [ __ ] out
yeah yes that he wanted to just ride
around and i don't know like with some
meant to happen it's going to happen so
i was over there and
you know what i mean i should ha it
happened like that and
my life was just flat before my eyes bro
i've seen people that i
really be cool with really hanging with
family members it's just
like i blacked out you feel me like from
the gun shells and i'm just seeing my
life like this
crazy [ __ ] but it's like it's like
that's when you see the light you think
that's what's crazy is they always say
right before you there's a um
some [ __ ] called uh
dimensionally what is dmt i don't know
what dmt stands for but there's a a
chemical called dmt you
you have it when you're born and right
before you die
and it's supposed to like when people
say they see the light
that's supposed to be what they see yeah
and
it's a there there's a way you could
smoke there's like
you could smoke dmt to feel that
now if you wanted to to try to like go
through some [ __ ] did you feel like when
you come out on the other side of it
you're in the hospital bed
did you feel like you went through some
[ __ ] that kind of maybe
changed your life yo yeah like
at that moment i think about my daughter
he's gonna say my mama my close friends
peers it's like
damn it could be over you so i'm saying
so
it's it's a my thing you feel me going
through that and
i bounced out of it and i just told
myself like the ignition i was doing
i'ma stop
i got to be more like like hands-on
about my life he's not saying and not
just
[ __ ] like fun and games and i mean like
[ __ ] is real and that should have been
over like it was over all this [ __ ] i
worked for all this you know what i mean
look at my daughters like of course of
course
so i know now you know i mean like do
the right thing
it's not [ __ ] off you feel me and i
think you'll be doing a good job on your
campaign [ __ ]
i so listen you got ice water records i
want to shout out to i'm from phoenix
he's someone i've been paying attention
to from arizona is a desert baby
who you've been working with yeah that's
my boy right there man we got a couple
of songs
he's working on his tape i just got a
squad i got i got a squad
i'm putting together man you know what i
mean ice water rock
dazzle baby perry on you putting
together the label
yeah the movement yeah just like it's
like a new day in time of
like a no limit or something cash money
but everybody got their own little
ways about you know what i mean like
life so it's about to be told
yeah i think i think what's crazy is
like your background in music
i think a lot of people associate you
with yg right yeah
so and shout out to yg's doing his thing
yeah
but i feel like you've done a very good
job of
creating your own [ __ ] yeah it was like
it was a time in my life like it was
just like a everywhere i go it's like oh
that's why she on me that's why g homie
so not to be offensive but nothing so i
took it by myself to separate it to
where they know slim for hunting
i mean like that's my boy that's my boy
i'm saying like that's life
from the hood yeah it's crazy because
like i remember meeting you originally
with yg over and over over the years
um and you know him and b moore and
and and just the whole crew like and
you've done a very
good job of just kind of like i don't
even when i think of slim 400 i
i used to always be like oh that's why
you know yg's
i just i think of you as your own entity
now yeah i had to put in that work you
feel me from the
songs i'm getting with people you know
what i mean like g-eazy looking out for
me you know what i mean
right like schoolboy q doing certain
[ __ ] for [ __ ] it's just
certain [ __ ] on them levels it
automatically showed the fans like
okay he is a stand-up guy by himself you
feel me what you're putting in a box is
your relationship with yg solid
yeah we good yeah like that's my bro you
say what i'm saying he's been through a
lot
of this and he's been through so many
areas of his career yeah ups and downs
and [ __ ]
ups and downs new management all kinds
of [ __ ] going on
yeah i think um i think
you know being as i always looked at yg
mustard and tai
as like our our generation snoop and
drink yeah
right the big brother [ __ ] yeah and it
was crazy because i
i mean i remember meeting yg in uh 2009
or 10 when twitter and buddha came out
yeah him tai and bobby brackens
oh yeah you remember that tour yeah it
was the uh
young and x-rated or young i don't know
they was on tour yeah
and bobby brackens was the biggest
artist on the tour
how crazy is that that's wow i was like
that was that was really the homie like
no no and shout out bobby he's a great
dude he's just [ __ ] i love that dude
but like
it's crazy to change that was [ __ ] 11
years ago
yeah and he was the biggest artist on
the tour ty was a nobody
yeah i didn't even realize he was the
dude on the tutor than buddha [ __ ] um
record nyg's a kid yeah you know what
i'm saying
what like what did you learn from being
around just because i do feel like we've
literally witnessed an entire generation
of west coast music progressed through
our eyes that you've been a part of
yeah what have you what did you learn
from being a being a witness to that
because that's history bro yeah
i feel like um they taught me how to
perfect my crowd bro just watching them
in a sense of you know making beats you
know what i'm saying tommy beats
uh muslim make b so i'm just sitting
there watching them how they put
together certain [ __ ]
and a real song making a real song you
say i'm saying or
they change up the whole verse i'm
saying or that's just sound type but
we got to change this line it just they
perfect that [ __ ] to the point where
it ain't just no oh i'm done with it you
feel me [ __ ] might come back tomorrow
and do some other [ __ ]
yeah looking at them work the way they
work is just like
tightening me up like all right i worked
a different way bro but
it made me a better worker when i looked
at them make you like more
more attentive to details and [ __ ] real
[ __ ] i feel like a lot of people they'll
do a record and they'll end it they're
like all right cool we're on to the next
one
i think you might go back in and make a
sound on the beat you can add some
[ __ ] strings that type of [ __ ]
they go farther than what a normal
rapper would go you feel me so
i tend to go [ __ ] you something this
album bombton that's officially out
right now
yeah talk about what what this album
means to you what it means to your
career man like this my life bro i feel
like this is kind of my best type of so
far
and now so we're creating we're
considering this a mixtape no it's like
an ep brother it's like an
album all right i don't know because we
never know anymore yeah
yeah nah when it's a mixtape you're
gonna know the mixtape i'm going back to
the old
og beast yeah okay okay okay right now
this is a real tape that's what i'm
saying and um
i would just tell my story on like i
said growing up on spruce being in
compton riding around the city like all
type of [ __ ] you feeling
yo interrupting your podcast experience
to tell you about our sponsor odd socks
by the way man can we just talk about
how amazing odd socks is as a company
not only do they give you the most
comfortable socks
in the world um they also have like you
know they got ric flair socks
they got [ __ ] spongebob socks for the
children if you're into oreos you know
shout out to all the fat [ __ ] out there
they got oreo socks they got pepsi socks
these are probably my favorites the
scarfaces listen they got all kinds of
[ __ ] going on at odd socks
not to mention they just launched
underwear they got slippers
they got masks and on the most
comfortable socks in the world you gotta
get the odd socks basics and thank me
later
go to oddssocks.com it's actually not
even on socks.com i should know it by
now
[ __ ] it's odd socksofficial.com
oddsoxofficial.comodsoxofficial.com
keywordbootleg kev and you'll save 20
percent
off your final order
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kev
go to oddsoxofficial.com and spend some
[ __ ] money and support the podcast
they're good people when you think of
people who come to la to visit
[Music]
and how compton has become
like a thing worldwide you know what i'm
saying i feel like in l.a
like south central content but compton
is like
it's like an iconic hood in the entire
world
everybody gotta count you gotta just you
can go buy a competitive visitor
you could buy a compton hat in australia
yeah you know what i'm saying
like is that something that do you
consider that to be a gift or a curse
because you know
people might not understand what that
means what all comes with that
it's a it's a curse you know i mean a
gift at the same time because
confidence is so wow you fit me in
haters
you know what i mean and the politics
the gang violence
[ __ ] like that so you can get caught up
in that you've been saying and you can
go to jail you could be dead you feel me
you see
they got shot there's a lot of [ __ ] come
with it but the name is itself comp in
the city
from easy now and all that type of stuff
of course man it's [ __ ]
straight out of compton man i love it i
got to see it so
it's a good thing it's a bad thing bro
let me ask you something when you watch
something like uh
like like the nwa movie right and that's
like a movie that's like really based
around your
your area and uh
again it's being consumed on a very
large scale
yeah there's white kids in
england watching straight outta come
yeah [ __ ] like you feel good and like
you know what like
look let's be honest compton is the most
famous area in la yeah
outside of hollywood it's people come to
l.a
and if they're like yo i want to go to
compton yeah you know what that means
right but you got some people that come
to
los angeles and this depending on who
they are they feel like
they just encounter because they i don't
know you'll be in hollywood
somebody don't want to go to the hood
well that's what i wanted to get you
right there you know everybody comes to
l.a
they go to hollywood they come to the
valley that's all they do
yeah they go to lax to hollywood they do
the little west hollywood [ __ ] they do
melrose all that
they get back on the freeway they get
back on that 405 they go back to lax to
go home
i feel like they're spitting or
something i ain't saying that but they
ain't seen that
so let's talk about like what like okay
obviously
for anybody watching this way from l.a
the valley is not la
hell no if you from san fernando if
you're from
it's encino north hollywood god bless
you that's not l.a
hollywood is not la what is real l.a
what you got to say like like south
central you stop saying
like all up and down [ __ ]
maine and broadway you said i'm saying
yeah i feel like there's just this big
disconnect from people who come and
visit
and be like yeah i was in l.a but like
where were you were you at like toku
madera in
west hollywood like it's not the same
thing they just say that [ __ ] this to be
sent in the most
la you were at was when you landed at
lax the the the suburb part of it
it's crazy right but no [ __ ] in a
straight hood bro they know what's
happening
um who do you consider real friends in
this rap game because there's a lot of
people we talked to earlier there's a
lot of associates there's a lot of
people you see at the club you might see
a playhouse whatever but who's like some
real homies in the rap game for slim 400
and mom and mom i feel like um
like i can't really say bro like i don't
want to like
i don't want to just say some [ __ ]
bro or speaking of people's names or
[ __ ] and it's like
like oh why didn't you mention my name
you feel me so that's fair you just
mentioned a few you know
listen right now you ain't got to
mention everybody but just mention a
couple that comes to mind
i feel like once again i said g-eazy
you're a good dude you said i'm saying
my [ __ ] yellow beezy good dude you feel
me like [ __ ] that be texting me
talking to me back and forth [ __ ] like
that so
i'll leave it like that you feel me it's
crazy because you said g-eazy
yeah and g-eazy a lot of people might
not think that of him
to be just on some humble [ __ ] hey first
of all it's my dog i love that guy
yeah and i know that about him but i
don't think a lot of people understand
that geez really tapped in
and he'd be showing love hell yeah how
did you originally
link up with him because a lot of people
you know been on tour and [ __ ] with yg
and um you know this the tour with uh yo
gotti yeah yeah and dj drama
someone we um you know just be back
behind stage got your little passes on
the [ __ ] so we running around before
the show doing whatever we're doing
eating going out of the you know what i
mean just doing different [ __ ] and now
every time he come across me here you
know i mean chop it up with me
see what i'm doing just asking different
questions about a [ __ ] you feel me it's
like bro he like doing this for what but
he's a good dude he was just uh like
trying to see what my mind was and
little do i know it's like i'm about to
reach out to him for this song but this
like
years after our relationship so we
already kind of built it so he
had no problem with doing this [ __ ] for
me you feel me that's dope
all right let me know were you at this
show celebrity theater
phoenix arizona mustard see jan
i'm hosting the concert is about 50
local acts yg is headlining
it ends up on world star people in the s
in the [ __ ]
in the in the crowd are are banging
their [ __ ]
yg starts throwing [ __ ] at them mustard
throw [ __ ] at them
[ __ ] became a viral ass moment were you
there for that [ __ ]
i want to say i was bro i want to say i
was
like i was i was with a side [ __ ] at
the time
i'm not with the uh girl i was with i
could say that now
that was with a little side [ __ ] at the
celebrity theater
and then like the promoter you know how
these promoters be they put 50 local
acts on charge each of them however much
amount of money to get their money back
therefore so the [ __ ] yg goes going
to 1 30 in the morning
i'm [ __ ] getting my dick sucked
backstage and i just hear [ __ ] going
crazy
and then like two weeks later it's on
youtube yg and
mustard and like and then there was
another issue
i just i know yg had a long he had a
hard time
getting the tour money because off the
rip he had kind of like been involved in
a lot of [ __ ]
not the i'm not the sale like that but
um
we we have words with some with some
[ __ ] guys out there you something behind
some [ __ ] and um
that's where all that [ __ ] took place
yeah there were some dudes in the clouds
just banging their shirts
[ __ ] yes all type of [ __ ] you know the
show i'm talking
attention doing your thing rapping so
you ain't really noticing that this [ __ ]
moving
we just keep seeing [ __ ] running
around just to keep [ __ ] that was crazy
that [ __ ] that was one of the craziest
shows because i remember it'd be so
crazy to sit tight
i remember seeing mustard take the
laptop stand and chuck it at these fools
and i know that laptop standing way
about 30 pounds hell yeah that little
solid
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] just happened over
here
straight up it's crazy because i feel
like you were fully a part of the
i remember i always used to tell yg i
used to tell b more this all the time
like
you know shout out to yg but man early
on in his career
the first four or five years he had a
real bad stigma attached to him
because of [ __ ] like that at shows was
like the craziest
situation out of town y'all ever been a
part of whether some crazy [ __ ] some
fights and whatever the [ __ ]
yeah like um look he says [ __ ] all the
time bro and i feel like we wasn't um
i said we was in miami doing some doing
a show and [ __ ] and
some other people got in the fight and
we kind of in the mix of them but
[ __ ] get to shoot this [ __ ] too so it
was like [ __ ] fighting through a chair
then now you hitting bullish shields and
[ __ ] so i'm trying to look for the team
make sure we all straight but
it just it's like you got a lot you got
to pay attention on here man i'm saying
[ __ ] to pop off any given moment when
you ain't even involved in this [ __ ] but
kind of in the mix yeah you know what i
thought what's up that happened recently
was on clubhouse
bad luck squashed his [ __ ] with mustard
on clubhouse
and i remember being at south by
southwest
in 2000 and
it was either 13 or 14. and i don't know
what happened but i know some [ __ ]
happened
um but it felt like yg had a lot of
tension with
uh it was a problem um
do you remember being around that era
yeah
you know what i think it was you know it
was basically it was about the thing
complete things i'm saying
[ __ ] have words you say i'm saying it
it took it went farther than what the
post has been but
you know people be slick talking you
know what i mean but it gets over that
[ __ ] now
i feel like that that was like a perfect
example of how
la street politics led into the music
[ __ ]
and it's like yo if we really think
about back then
how fire would have been to see problem
and yg work together for do a whole
[ __ ] album together
like problem had it like both of them
had some like they had it you know what
i'm saying
that era was so legendary in la history
like
problem had welcome to mollywood yga
just read up like it was a whole
movement and both of them from the same
city and it was some l.a politics [ __ ]
sometimes gets in the way of some
historical [ __ ] do you feel like with la
the politics sometimes because you know
i just had this conversation with um
with big u and whack we're talking about
how
sometimes the la politics have gotten in
the way of some real historical [ __ ]
happening in hip-hop
all that type of [ __ ] yeah because it
might not be
rapper a and rapper b having a real
problem with each other it's not about
that it's about
the politics of flow to run around them
and above them you know what i'm saying
is that some people
other like me being artists i hang with
a sun crew
this artist hanging with certain crew
i'm saying somebody it's like they'd be
having an inner beast so it's looking
like
it's a artist thing but it'd be really
the friends and
yeah yeah it ain't even about like you
ain't ma'am i don't even have a [ __ ]
problem with the guy
yeah but it's like hey i might be from
here and you might be from here but so
because of that like this and this don't
mesh
yeah oh you had a record with bad luck
yeah we fall uh yeah i mean that's what
i'm saying we got we cool it's just
[ __ ] be falling out behind other [ __ ]
so yeah well i thought it was dope
i just thought it was real dope to see
bad luck and uh and mustard get on
clubhouse and talk that [ __ ] out yeah
because it's like
yeah we're talking about some serious
errors of la hip-hop like
you know problem might not had had
and i know problem could have signed
with anyone at that when one problem was
was [ __ ] lit out here everyone
offered him a deal
but like to think he had that whole like
side of la hip hop and then yg
i mean yg we're talking about now he's
one of the i look at yg like our our
modern day snoop yeah you know what i'm
saying if kendrick is
dre yg is snoop
you know what i'm saying so i just think
that uh
yeah i always thought that was like a
and and what's cool about that though
too is i
don't feel like it ever really kind of
bled through the music too much yeah
kind of stayed behind mine it was minor
[ __ ] that was said and spoke on here and
there and certain little disc songs and
you know i mean minor [ __ ] but yeah for
the most part it didn't get too
out of hand so the new album bombton is
out this is
you've been staying independent shout
out to empire
yeah um why stay independent
why i mean and and and mind you you got
ice water records so kind of give me the
rundown of what's going on
moving forward the album is out yeah i
feel like i'm just you know what i mean
like
lining myself up to be a real seat
excuse me a real ceo bro and
a lot of the people up so as far as the
label deal
i feel [ __ ] can sign with a major don't
get it twisted but
it'd be [ __ ] that you can't do
when you used to do it you can't do what
i know what's going on in these streets
so why would i drop that when i'm just
doing it because you doing it but
when i drop it on my name the people be
like what you doing like
it'd be different [ __ ] when it's another
label so being independent is better
because you got your layout
you can drive whatever you want whenever
you want from me
so and then you building you something
you're building on your own [ __ ]
now looking back years you saying it's
like damn like i went from here to
nothing
i mean i went from nothing or something
you know what i'm saying a lot like
that's what i was telling you bro i feel
like i went from like always
thinking of you and yg together to just
thinking of you guys as two separate
entities
yeah you did a great job of carving your
own [ __ ] bro yeah
i know it's hard to do so man tell
everybody well you know just
stay stay stay true to yourself and your
craft if you feel me you're going to get
there for sure for sure
we'll go support the new album bomton
ice water records
is it going to be anything coming out
from the label soon any artists anybody
who's dropping
i got my peoples coming in like probably
another like another month and a half or
something i'll probably drop the ice
water won't be taken so it's going to be
like a
like a compilation with all of us you
something says if there's a baby
so desert babies officially ice water
records arizona let's go y'all people
hey listen he's from az got my support
that part i got the cardinals hat on you
know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying that's my city
man so let's go yo slim 400
bombed in the album is out bullet kept
podcast let's go